[Music]
don't let
me for
don't don't this
and
then
[Music]
contact that obstruction there a little
more Dynamic so when our drills we do
this
stuff this one un clear you see
l l then Center
Center
CER
don't don't clear then find it don't arm
Center
C see Center compact
but deviate Center is still
there make
sense a
little it goes off
then let's try this uh you're coming in
and I just move here you see that I
don't clear the arm
is
that
keep
arms keep you want to go on this the arm
but every every time you see
Center Center
you understand we're trying to lose
the the external to the
center so make it forget the defending
yourself touch and move me
immediately
touch
touch touch don't try to Parry you
already you already are touching touch
moving so I'm not going to touch you and
bring your I touch you and move
you touch and
move touch and
move so pay attention see how this arm's
moving here's that
arm this arm's moving me
to this to I put together
it's not one off other on
see moving this
one so what's happening
is you can do the Y you see if this
one's going
this and
Ive you
understand so
when you push on me and you generate the
connection now you see and that stuck
feeling you can work with
that but this arm starts to go off as it
goes in you
see this arm does not
going you see that okay so that's what
we're working
on
contact go ahead and let it press like
you like now move it
around you careful use that you're going
to use this
here if here keep it
catch
contact keep it keep it going don't get
stuck here this keeps going yes
yes
slow get it
keep it keep it keep
it one
more keep it
there keep it in
slow keep
it try
not you good
so that want you push just keep it
[Music]
don't let for the power
okay so you feel Stu right here right
you're trying to lift it okay got it
so we're not going to walk
backwards if you're losing this if
you're trying to lift it you feel feel
stuck don't lift it let go of your
hand let go with your
hand pull it up now you're not lifting
it stop stop now you're not lifting it
it's here you see that okay so you'll
keep going around and you use your elbow
you don't lift your hand it's right here
on your elbow just push in for you feel
it push toward there it is right there
you see it goes
around does that make sense so you were
here and you're here
[Music]
no okay remember
every contest can only manifest because
you generate in your participation and
you have the power to De participate and
when you do the contest syst
okay so here it is again go back you got
out of that contest okay but then you
have it
here it's right there yes
we
off for
[Music]
keep it so you're like what can I do
with it sometimes you might have to go
with two y you want to okay
but if you pull if you I it this way
this will open up with less M yes
good
[Music]
good where's my gu play you think
this
way
this this
one for
you
lifting yeah
okay so this is not a problem use the
that
shoulder you could touch the
arm but don't try to lift the arm you're
going to use that shoulder to find
my this keeps me going
boom use the shoulders
the go off my shoulders use the should I
would protect so you don't come up with
my face in some way but I'm going to use
the
[Music]
shoulders
okay see you guys good if it happens you
should try to clear up
there to many steps
backs on should be on now turn that no
you don't have to turn you just turn
your
claw you out your
hips so turn my
it's not
right okay so you go around me but I
don't I don't paint
the
yes clear
when you crb you you immediately go
and you go into contact shit's going to
get through there it is there
[Music]
see I wouldn't do it that way I
clear you'd have to earn it
clear make sense yes but if if it
happens don't
go try to get it off release you see
release release
for
arm El
okay don't fight take a
little all right you're
saying so de comment I need to
release and I'm obviously out of breath
and that wasn't even very many reps and
it wasn't even very long yeah and so
that means I'm holding my breath and
that means you're flexing I'm f in and
is not and that means you're
contesting you see and contesting
means you're self
reifying
okay what we're doing in the training is
reversing all
that oh I stop their self reify that's
the what you release so self- reify
means that the self is in its
regular
Perpetual Construction
see and the nature of that is
opposition meaning the self is always
constructed in dichotomy to what it
considers
nonself okay and that concentrically
expands out and makes a dichotomous
experience of the
world so
because it
experiences the world through what
supports the
self and what contests itself self it
makes us exist in a constant state of
contestation so iido
jiujitsu having taken non-c contestation
as its
Paradigm is like a counter remedy like a
vaccine do you see to that contesting
aspect of self reification
okay so if you pay
attention for
example to those shoulder ones or the
bicep ones in which you were trying to
get the hand off of your shoulder or you
were trying to get the hand up off your
bicep when you when you pushed against
it do you
see it became very
heavy and in its
heaviness you started to feel very weak
see and the self doesn't want to feel
weak because it's threatening to it
wants to feel powerful and so to
continue constructing itself it has you
lift up on those things see lift
harder but if we
release that possible
contestation don't lift it let it touch
you
there then you don't feel the weakness
anymore which for a moment we felt was
surely there and the only thing I could
feel you see but when I
released and I let you touch the bicep
and I used the
bicep you
see then I did not feel weak you never
felt strong to me I did not feel
threatened and so this is the downside
of the
self-construct is because it exists only
through
contest in the dichotomy of self versus
no self only through contest it
experiences the world in a constant
state of of threat it feels threaten you
see and this is
why and how
buddo uses the warrior Paradigm and the
warrior ideal of no fear of Bravery of
Valor as a counter Paradigm to the
self's Paradigm of Life lived in fear
life lived under right
see so and you do this stuff what what
you have to do as your training is is is
feel your
effort feel where it
is feel your lifting feel your straining
feel your tension you see feel your
pushing feel them pushing on you which
requires you pushing on them J feel for
those
[Music]
moments and like puzzle
let them fall
apart by stop doing that stop
participating in the
contest it's an Act of Faith
because yourself is like don't
do it you see don't do
it and that that's why faith is in here
and why faith is an Act of Valor okay
you have
to uh trust that that what I'm telling
you is true the push you feel the
weakness behind it the shorty that comes
with all that is not true it's a
delusion created by the
self-construct so you just have to risk
it by I feel myself pushing I feel them
pushing on me that I know is me pushing
on them I'm going to stop that and now
you will trust TR that I won't feel
their push anymore okay now we've
reduced as you said we've reduced the
environment enough
that it's safe enough if I fail you see
you're not going to get punched in the
face or stabbed or knocked out okay but
you can take from
that how the
self experiences all level of threat as
if it's dead
do you see or great injury to yourself
okay so you have to be aware of that
this this self doesn't draw a
distinction in in uh in degrees like
this is low level like you said but yet
in the moment I couldn't treat it like
it was low level because the self never
treat every little no self every little
contest every little threat to the self
oo is is experienced as if it is you're
facing death there's no return from this
okay so you have to know that too know
that's going to happen Okay so use that
use this kind of knowledge in a way to
risk it we're not you try to get your
intellect in there somehow because we're
going slow and light it is possible you
can do it okay
um what I'm pointing out here is you're
going to feel the
push you're going to use your knowledge
to tell you that's me pushing on them
I'm going to not
push it's going to feel like I'm going
to die keep not pushing because you know
it's not true and then find the
technique okay because we're going slow
and smooth and I'm really feeding you
the cues you need for this this is all
doable
okay all
right um go ahead and get change and
anything else to say on that yeah
so when I feel the push because I don't
want to against it then my tendency is
to hyper is to hyper
y to let go of that yes and and this is
another trick of that mind because
dichotomist you see and dichotomy is two
sides of the same
coin and it's like a it's like
a like a trick on a
kid the kid goes uh the kid sees the
coin that has heads on it and the kid
goes no no no I want the one with the
eagle find the one with the eagle and
you turn it over and you go oh here's
one with the eagle do you see not
realizing is still the head coin on the
other side so yeah you have to keep that
in mind too but I'm training you through
my touch and
my
um my internals inside your body that
won't come up today but it does come up
okay but it won't come up
today okay trust me okay all right
all
right you can try to break
[Music]
NOP no
grip still not gripping just sticking
you
see this this fine come in again
s not
[Music]
pushing okay we're fine that's it there
it is
it trust it's here it's here it goes
that way NOP it's right here I know that
you don't feel like that but that's what
I was trying to show you I can stick
anywhere there it is right
there
yes you're always looking for ledges
yes
yesing all let's go back so somewhere in
there you desired something desire is
from that self so I came in
here okay and then you didn't like that
cuz but if you look at it to you it's
not a
ledge it
is so
you stick sck find the ground wait
wait move it this way no this way yes no
you don't need to turn it you're moving
it this way it'll stick trust yes
yes okay but you always want ledges
I've never I almost never have a ledge
you see never have a
ledge there's no ledge on the side of
your face you see I'm not trying to hook
your ear or anything
okay even though that elbow's there I
don't try to hook in it I'm here like
this
okay there it is again
[Music]
there's no magic to the to what I
normally grab
with here or what I normally push with
anywhere is you can find it anywhere
anywhere see anywhere anywhere it goes
off you find it here see it's still
there boom right you pass it you don't
need to grab it pass
it okay so let's identify
that I'm still thinking
materially meaning I'm thinking with the
things that I always used to push with
and now I'm free from pushing so I'm
free from having to use the things only
that I was used to pushing with okay
feel more the energy
good so you see how you feel some weight
there so don't lift it hold on Stick
here instead of lifting it stick there
there it is right
yes okay you see how different that is
okay all
right we're just
playing four grab attemps
okay it says see he had initially his
palm on you but then your hand came onto
his forearm and then he used the forearm
to do it he didn't try to get back his
hand on me okay that's the example of
what we're talking about should keep
going
[Music]
okay go back and Rewind the film rewind
rewind break break apart okay your hands
should be reaching for him okay a reach
good and start reaching for him reach
for him
yes reach for him
again okay
[Music]
good so there he is using his the chest
you see let you have the chest
reach
again
okay good good good good good well
careful well watch your desire please
goow okay especially in a non drug
got it all right
[Music]
strength your deviation
shink
you're
get her Center get her Center get her
Center
thank you very much
I'm doing less inside you right
now got train hard
train more years don't no no need to
hook it it should be f
you're hooking
again it's right here if you pull this
out if you I see it that way this will
get young you can project one there it
is
St
okay for
get off it
yes okay try
[Music]
get off it get out of there
so
this
uh don't uh give up
TI
to don't come here and give them that
should might as well work on grip
clearing and but sometimes it gets
through I'll does that make sense so
clear the
grip angle
there yes
there nothing for
[Music]
free switch
let's go
baby better
[Music]
reach for that other hand okay so don't
that's that to me that's one of those
things like that's not really going to
work okay I let you grab my shoulder and
you're playing with your good base like
I'm kind of do you understand but
he he loses his base a little he pushes
through whatever you see okay then then
I'm not so F so that's what I mean
nothing for free okay same thing uh you
have one hand you see and then that
comes that hand and then no no no you
should be looking for that hand already
see he runs into that your other hand
should be up okay
switch you should expect it to come
[Music]
Swit stay connected in between you you
shut off too much in
between stay in
there careful that's a lot of weight
right
good yeah use it use it there there use
your where touching there you go you you
you're like uh uh uh uh it's right there
just don't start pushing on it
[Music]
good reach yes yes yes
good okay so uh one
time you cleared on the on the here like
this you're here like this okay and then
she turned on you you see okay and then
you kind of
here here you have to be
aware because I'm on the line you see
and this is easy to the double leg or
the tackle or I'm going to lose the
center line okay so you're here like
that we're turning she turns around you
see you have to start working her the
other way okay if you step back so
notice I step back but I brought her
this way to me I'm not going to step
back on that line and then wait and take
another step and then you find be
careful when you get back on the line
okay uh the other you could do give her
like that and she comes coming around
right coming around and you just t con
again keep the same angle right she
keeps trying to come around you can t
con the other way
combining into two yes okay the other
thing you do she comes around boom pump
right and you're line all
right here it is no off okay uh
when you're here like that don't lower
the head with that hand yes you see that
know don't don't do it okay so you want
the head lower Balls to the pelvis the
head came down okay or uh I lower the
arm head came down and then I have it
okay all
right
try don't push on things yes
good that's a good
movement yes there's the head you see hi
good yes good good and that was you you
tried to deflect but she got on the
shoulder so that she whenever that
happens you're not quite out balance and
now it's easier when you project from
your shoulder okay switch shoulders
[Music]
we're going to get rid of those Ledges
okay don't try anything that's going to
be your intention that's going to be the
self-
construct okay there's nothing wrong
with you're what you're
doing
good now see this is I want variation do
you see that I don't I don't variation
happens on its own because the natural
rule is never going to repeat itself we
seek variation we're seeking control
when we seek control the
Selfies okay so don't get tired of what
you're doing okay I try it
again you're never doing the same thing
twice don't
worry good don't go off stay in your
mind reaching out to him
okay mine with
him don't don't worry if it
goes keep
going watch the hooks watch the
grbs yep you had you were
fine you got to get that hat in there
you reach for the hand not it shows up
and then we
go ultimately I don't want to
have see ultimately yes you understand
especially in a drill like this okay so
we're we're here we about to
grappling that's it so that first little
projection is where his join open you
see and now his his balls are there
right so now now you have him right you
understand so careful
the reason why you don't want variation
is because you want
refinement
so as you're as you're getting bored
with doing
that you should go I don't have to do
that do you see you get that and I let
me have another chance at
it do you understand I I keep working
refinement as opposed to variation okay
take a break all right you were saying I
feel like a one of the most notable
differences between my technique in
yours is the um the yin yield The
Disappearing and how you're able to
shrink the technique so much um mine is
still just very gross and like much more
on the young aspect if you will than
really that that disappear that you get
with that yeah um let's first point
out that there's levels to training okay
and then let us acknowledge that
the that mind that we're trying to
deconstruct always wants the level we're
on to be the highest level even if it's
a piece of level you get like it's
it it if you just analyze just a
little that we're in a total
place it's not
uncommon let's say let's say it's
somebody who's worked with me in all my
Decades of training people it is not
uncommon for somebody to want me to do
the sign of the cross over their piece
of place like please validate my
piece of place do you see
that's always going to be a
problem because that's just the
self so that you come to the wrong
person do you see I cannot
validate that I can only destroy that
okay
so what your experiencing is a little
bit of
that well you're experiencing it well I
just want to point
out it's a little bit of
that and then the teacher saying okay
everything you've done up to here it's
not good anymore do do you see that and
you've been around long enough and
you've developed enough Faith to realize
that's how it goes you see
um but this is where we have to go now
okay you did what you're doing what you
were doing out there is very high very
high you can't see it anywhere else but
in from this Dojo you just can't it's
not anywhere
okay but it's and while it is high
compared to everywhere else and while it
is a necessary step and I did want you
to be able to do that and I brought you
there we're not going to stay there okay
um and then you should know that after
you learn to get
smaller I'm going to do something else
which will be totally different from
that okay um but here let's focus in on
this void aspect
okay um this is huge because at
the
cosmologically at the
center is this void this shunyata this
emptiness do you
see this the da
is you could have called it void you
could have called it God because it's
Indescribable without limit no
delineation our word for that is void
okay and that is where we're
headed and that means thereby
concentrically there should be a
void in the middle of my physicality in
the middle of my movements and in the
middle of my
energetics do you see and so if I can
now draw your
attention you you should feel I I know
you do but I don't know if you're aware
enough of it you'll
feel I'm about
to feel a y but there's nothing nothing
there
and next thing you
feel is
something but it comes from another
angle where you're where you're not
expecting it or where it's taking you
off balance you see so the first the
first
Contact is on void is on the emptiness
which makes sense because it's in a no
self State and so
you you you're touching me this is the
difference it's not that I get out of
the
way you're touching
me but that Touch goes through me do you
see and that's where you get hyper
compressed so to speak that's how I I
think about it I get you in a deeper
Yang State inside my body and then all
of a sudden I just redirect it do you
see and so you feel like um and I'm sure
it's on the video I haven't seen the
video but I'm sure it's
like the UK gets
in deeper and then all of a sudden like
a like a
percussion do you see but not a hard one
it could be hard but it doesn't have to
be hard do you know what I'm talking
about and so this is important this is
very very important
um because
that no
self phys physical manifestation of
voidness void
whatever is the dro the dropped mind do
you see so you're doing your zazen
that's the state you hang out in when
you're doing this okay and so
now are Kon or
iido becomes a constant
repetition of ego tripartite mind
drop ego Tri partti mind drop do you see
and so this is just repetition of the
skill of deconstructing the self and so
now you can do
it anywhere you see while you gain the
benefits of at least a few hours a night
I keep taking taking it apart taking it
apart taking it apart you
see so it's very very key and and so to
make it
smaller obviously I'm not getting
smaller do you see but I'm letting you
in more so I don't need the big angles
of deviation because I'm not in a
physical contest with you as a edge to
an edge you know a border to a border I
just need a little angle offset but if
you pay attention I'm on the line of
attack but your energy is not pushing on
me it's pushing through me do you see
and so that was all I need to Boom give
a
little deflection to get you off the
line do you see that
um so where to
look not in smaller feet work do you see
that would be a physical trying to find
a physical solution it's in more let
them push more on you so your Technique
was very nice in that you weren't ever
where they could push on you but what
I'm doing is I'm where you can push on
me do you
see does that make sense okay so that's
that's where we're going and when you
get there you increase the Y
internalization and things like Co you
are now increased cuz your y output is
increased cuz your y input is increased
you see and so you can make smaller
movements to get the same thing which as
you see I all I did on that one move was
Square you up and open All I Need You
square up and I'm going to kick the
balls I'm going to rupture the out
on you see and this thing is over this
it's over at that point you don't need
the big things that the training DRS
have where they go across the M or so I
also don't need those big angles per se
those big footwork angles okay but it
was very nice you did very very nice
stuff uh as you were going so we're
where we need to be but we're not
hanging out here that's the best way of
looking at things okay you're you're
exactly where you need to be so same
thing that you couldn't have done this
last year no freaking way not even close
okay okay
um but we're not going to hang here do
you see we're not going to hang
here
okay thank you very much s thank you